alright happy Thursday everybody I'm
Eric if you guys didn't know that
already
hope you guys are having a good Thursday
I'm lone wolf in it today as you can see
there's like an empty chair like right
there everyone's really busy with evil
within - I think the review is being
written up and done and video review and
today we also streamed that yesterday on
nightmare mode me and John Luke so if
you haven't watched that yet you might
want to check that out but yeah weekly
reset I know it's Thursday it's not
Tuesday it's been a kind of crazy week
but we're gonna do the inverted spire
nightfall
which has some new modifiers this week
attrition and the one where you kill
stuff to get time basically so it looks
like I'm gonna have to figure out how to
do this nightfall because some of the
people that I normally would run it with
aren't on because as you can see the
clan is not very uh very popping right
now as it wouldn't be it is 11:00 a.m.
Pacific time I have four out of the five
pieces Bob my problem is mmm can barely
hear Clan audio olan
or game audio that is ah my problem is I
have opened up 20 packages at least I
think let me see what does it say 19
close to 20 I was close I've opened up
19 package we'll talk about iron banner
in a second iron banner is back soon
probably I'm gonna do the prestige knife
all Jason just because I don't have my
my group also hello to all the people
saying hello and YouTube chat manual
crass say yet
Seiya ninja okay
I totally butchered that one sorry
what's up sure Eze and squiddy ashokan I
noticed you don't worry hi gamers life
so yeah I'll try to monitor chat to the
best of my abilities what's up Hassan
cosign can I join your clan I think
we're running out of roster spots but
potentially you can send through a
request we're just getting small client
so I have four pieces of the the iron
banner stuff but uh unfortunately don't
have it all yet it's kind of pissing me
off to be honest I'm not really a big
fan of the new system and we can as I
mentioned we can talk about that later
people still play this yes iron banana
is back as Joseph Elliott says what's up
sitting 23 oh I don't really want to
sell her the knife also roster wasn't
looking too hot either because there's
like one person I got two pieces from
five packages that's a pretty good luck
I've gotten two dupes I've got like
three dupes I think I finally got the
helm last night but I really want the
arms so yeah IV fusion seems amazing if
you have I don't have a Jason I don't
have the fusion or the SMG and that's
with 19 packages which is pretty bad
news in my opinion you know what let's
just start with iron banner I guess what
do you get after 10 packages all you get
is this emblem this one which is very
cool
and like some shaders that's kind of
about it it's not I don't know like I'm
not a huge fan of the reward system for
the iron banner this time around we
already did evil within - yesterday ho
sign so if you want to check that out
you can looking try soloing the knife
wall but it probably really rough that
armor looks outstanding yeah it does
look pretty good I'm missing the arms
got four out of five right now we can
just give this some sort
sure grenades ants are good well let me
put the key back on guided Games
nightfall I mean we could try to do
guided Games nightfall I think it's
gonna be that's actually that's actually
not a terrible idea do I need to have my
coins out though
do I dare do all right you know what
let's try it let's try guy two games
select and meet a clan to guide you
through the nightfall or oh yeah I have
to do this one cuz cuz I can't do the
other one I need to clan mates do the
other one let's try guided games that's
a good call Bob Jones alright yeah got
to be helpful a tentative observant
willing to learn and friendly are they
gonna kick me because I don't have a mic
though that's my problem here I don't
and then bring them Mike in with me crap
I'm gonna get Shepard here hopefully
they don't require you to have them like
chat is required what
right no dude this could take hella long
so one guy in a reddit post said that
one day he was kind of like as a clan
founder he was just had free time he
wanted to sharp a group
do you see the 20-minute wait time
I don't want to wait 20 minutes did you
finish all the bosses in cuphead I
didn't I'm stuck on the dragon but I
haven't played in a couple days yeah
there's only one guy on right now that I
don't really play with I met him a long
time ago all right you know what let's
just try it let's just try it solo we'll
see how it goes I think it's gonna be
really tough though I'd have to play
really slow and I don't do a good job of
that you look like Elvis in that armor
yeah it's pretty it's pretty dope it's a
it's like elvish samurai style I really
like the helmet the the arms are really
cool because they have wolves on the
shoulders I like that I like the
aesthetic I'm not a huge fan of the sash
or the mark the the Titan mark it's not
very I know I've never been a fan cloaks
hunters got it best let me quit this let
me quit my job so we can do this knife
pulses good yeah you like either the IV
shaders uh yeah I'd play with folks in
the chat if there's a couple people in
chat that want to do the nightfall
hit me up juice and gin PSN oh I always
forget that my Titans the only character
unluckily
that has the insta squad Sparrow
everyone oh no it's a bug Oh someone
roll through yes I got a free pass guys
batter is just different this week I
haven't played this week yet actually
I say play iearnt banana till you get
more people to help with the night ball
yeah that's probably true we can see if
I can do this
uh but Bob sorry I do like one of the
two shaders I like the one that's less
green I've never been a fan of I'm just
not a fan of green in general the only
thing that in my you know my entire life
that I thought was cool that was green
was probably the Green Ranger tommy play
that that dagger flute called the
Dragons or baby but that's that's about
it other than that no I stick to mono
colors like blue black white pink Ray's
I'm not sure the David Sherman saying
the loo system is a complete joke five
packages so far on my Titan for them the
grenade launcher oh wow okay I've never
had it that bad
bring back the damn vendors with the
stuff I can actually buy yes I agree a
hundred percent David we will talk about
my iron banner woes my blues my just my
thoughts on the loot system in general
it's not it's not very good not this
time around at least for iron banner I
thought it was fine for the that was
totally fine for the factions but I do
not like how it's working out for the
for the iron banner it's it's very
grindy it's very slow it's the orangey
on it's really not so great so well this
is totally weird so this so they do this
investing obviously where they change it
up it's not like your normal nightfall
or I start inverted strike where you
know I would be dealing with minotaurs
and crap like that
so hopefully the problem with this
week's is that it's attrition which is
kind of scary because I can't really
Zerg down the boss later obviously is a
concern
I just got a I got a play maximum okay
I'm gonna before job ready
I already
please drop some stuff that yeah I can
heal me
already kind of little sketch
you know I always have a rocket question
but I'm really bad
just stop being annoying you Hydra
thank you
cool alright not doing terribly not
doing great
here we go when destiny to come out on
PC October 24th we'll have a launch
livestream that day yeah this strike is
nearly all vex as Jason CK thank you for
that Jason appreciate it yeah most
people are not a fan of the new IB
unfortunate I think it's I always like
to IB but it just really is unfortunate
that this the way the loop system is
working this time around is not just as
mentally not so hot as mentioned open 19
packages only have four out of the five
pieces of armor even during the faction
stuff I got pretty screwed on my warlock
which was new monarchy I only got I
never finished the set and that was 30
packages that's what's making me scared
about the iron banner is that like it's
so grindy and all I want really is the
armor sets because I think outside of
the outside of the fusion rifle and the
SMG I'm not actually sure if the weapons
or any of the other weapons aren't good
from what I've read so that's also
mildly concerning is that there just
aren't I mean that's kind of how it went
before though it's like the same most of
the weapons weren't so great so I guess
the only good news for us so far is that
there is at least a lot of stuff to kill
so oh please don't shoot
so I think if we just play it slow
enough and keep killing the stuff maybe
we'll be all right I don't know we'll
find out
oh okay maybe we won't be alright uh do
you see costs already out there IV pulse
is good yeah I think Ivy's pulse is
pretty good Wheatley it's weird because
nightshade outclasses it like when you
just compare them spec wise but it
shoots a lot faster so that kind of
makes up for it I just playing on normal
ps4 it's not we would never stream like
4k not never but wouldn't be anytime
soon the costs to stream that would be
really high anything David sure mean at
this rate not for much longer
yeah that's why true I'm running out of
things to do I mean I'll be honest but I
think even they must know that because
they're like deal with the first DLC so
soon it's in like December I think so
I just feel like there's like way less
am I crazy is there just less minions is
that what it is I mean maybe it is oh
here they come
you know yeah they totally come
oh I ran out of thing
Oh
the circle launcher area
to get out of there fast as night falls
yeah well I'm trying to sell the wait
what's your power level 3 or 5 I get
shredded when I try to sell than I fall
maybe I'm just bad no I mean I'm getting
shredded but my attentions kind of
slightly being diverted
what's up canal de rainbow 6 siege siege
that's a long name yeah I wouldn't be
shocked if this is pretty tough like
anytime you have even a second Guardian
it helps a lot right just because you
know someone else is being shot at you
can get take time to feel and whatnot
and here we can't do that so that's
clearly not working
I mean we're not doing great on time
probably to be honest
ghetto people's car needed
yeah cuz the thing too is like you can
get easily overwhelmed solo is that
other guy not here there's the other guy
what
there's the other city always down there
all right there
I suppose fair okay
it's got help
like I have a feeling I'm not doing good
time-wise I have no idea though does
anyone know if I'm doing good or bad
right now
based off of previous nightfall
experiences tricky I mean this week I'm
done at this at all this week so on
high-caliber rounds
oh I went way too far
game please you guys are supposed to be
fighting each other housing that dead
I can't wait til the last boss really
I'm so excited also you would think that
that light would give me more oh God
nope nope nope
No
oh cool he like one-shotted me
you need at least four minutes at the
boss Oh God
if you want help I'm logged on ps4 right
now yeah you can add me juice and gin
Justin Martha says destiny too is just
for casuals and is very lackluster
I don't think it's actually just for
casuals it feels for casuals anyone
could do this nightfall Solo takes three
players about two and a half minutes to
kill the last boss sick especially it's
2003 also harkening four minutes yeah
we'll see
that's fine
no no I need that I need that
restorative life that's stupid that it
has physics
so basically you're saying I'm pretty
boned then
let's hope this thing launches in the
right direction it's going to be a short
okay we can cross the dig site
we can make it there Holly should have
killed that stuff is my guess I hope I
don't fail this jump I tend to fail it
yep okay well well okay normally I
wouldn't kill these guys but I might not
have a choice need some light back
gosh darn it there's so many harpies
okay it'll be fine it'll be fine
I believe the chapelier's I believe
and okay 339 just run yeah I probably
should just ran I need some life though
bone to life no that's no definitely not
all right no like this not like this
please not like this
oh this is this is not this is not the
business guys oh there's a Hobgoblin
there too don't excite me I'm dead
oh is it gonna start me from the
beginning I sure AM and hope hope to god
that I made it come on
the trick to that jump is to walk into
launch or not jump or run into it yeah
probably just run the next bit yeah it's
kind of late for that let's say hi to
the boss 100% okay maybe we won't
hundred percent say hi to the boss
nope all right I lied I think that you
might not be able to say hi to the boss
yeah I can see that Richards later
saying it's all the ads of the last boss
that make it difficult not the you're
not gonna do it yeah I know I know
trust me I know I don't realize do i do
want to say hi to the boss though
okay all right
and sometimes you gotta know you gotta
know when to when to fly to orbit all
right what we're gonna do is we're gonna
check the friends listing and then see
if we can get a bit of of course of
course why every time I fix this
somebody breaks it all right hold on
hold on sorry there's nothing fun about
nightfall in d2 I guess I can go see
Gihon is one of those people so I've
just added that person and see if that
person responds here I'll get them back
in uh they needed they needed something
to raise the difficulty of the nightfall
[ __ ] Jeff or G off depending on how you
look at it or how you say your name
properly and the time thing was a way to
kind of add tension and I think it does
it does well when like you know you're
not by yourself this is the easiest
nightfall by far but still no solo
mission yeah anything what the fire team
is obviously easier Wheatley I've added
you so if take that forever quest and
then I'll add you in here
thank you for also offering to help
all right there we go all right we got
two people I feel pretty confident feel
pretty confident
let's inspect our buddy here
got the roster I really hate how the
roster is not on options anymore oh dude
all it takes is one person man how are
you max clan level I don't know we just
have a lot of people playing every day
every week all right he's going cold
heart the morgue indeed nameless he's
got the chest piece from iron beignets
he's got his clan banner it's cool so
yeah yeah my client pretty much started
from day one uh I wouldn't say that
Geoff that you can sprint through a
mission and the night falls anymore like
there's certain areas you can obviously
skip but it's definitely not always the
case especially with like the one was it
last week then one or two weeks ago
maybe the the that one with the lasers
the name is eluding me oh we don't get
to cheat this time
dude this is all this time I lost that
first time around
all right looking good feels a lot
easier should be picking up all the
light sources if you need one more I'm
in yeah possibly Devesh Patel you can
add me on PSN juice and gin
if I don't get you in for the nightfall
I still need a four stack for the iron
banner so we could totally do that after
this so yeah probably more that we could
take a fourth person to iron banner so
if someone in chat wants to play some
iron banner here after this nightfall
that I'm doing with the I think those
Wheatley hit me up on PSN and we'll get
that going and then I'll talk about how
I'm pretty salty about iron banner and
how it should be a lot better than it is
what it is
the fact that you're being hurried is
the main issue yeah I could see that but
they're supposed to be ways for you to
get that time back right so right now
it's killing enemies and like now
maybe it's not so great solo but I mean
just having Wheatley here or go seigen
as PSN is already making me feel a lot
more confidence Jessie I haven't seen
your son and unfortunately I wouldn't
think you could just win your son back
but maybe someone has them captive I
don't know
so yeah again I'll be taking down to
Iron Man with some people and chat after
this if they want to do some gym
punchy's
yeah I've added one person here I think
the beach wanted in so I can always
rotate if there's a lot of people that
want to play
can i play iron banner earth uses Rio
spearmen shirt I try to get as many
people in as I can obviously if you've
played one match or whatever then I'm
like cycling people out depending on if
there's a lot of interest
don't move that was too far wasn't it
I'll just go down there with him
that pulsar name is Sophie
all right looking good looking good [ __ ]
lot of primary what's your gamertag
juice Ju IC e the letter n and then J n
hopefully we can get some wins in Egypt
after 30 reward packages you might get
your son it's all orangey that's true
you might get them back but lord saladin
who has been a complete douche bag
component is probably gonna not give you
these all iron banner is Uriel's gift of
my two last hope and a bunch of sweats
that can't play for fun yeah yeah I
don't use mighta as much as I used to in
terms of other than trials maybe I
haven't even trials until a couple weeks
now we can mess around with some iron
banner guns though I like that as
someone mentioned earlier I do you like
the iron banner pulse quite a bit but
yeah Orioles is too good because I think
it's the reason why it's good is because
it has high caliber rounds and it's
pretty stable so yeah it's just kind of
too good not to use I keep trying to use
other guns like prosecutor
and what not but Uriel's is if I'm even
saying right really really it's just too
good just too good in my opinion
so kinda is what it is I suppose
repeat that for me slower like juice
like orange juice and then the letter M
and then J I am
and when the flags are captured you get
spawn camp yeah I don't know like I feel
like you guys must have been experienced
a lot of sweaty matches because I don't
feel like they all go that way our this
is gonna be a risky maneuver aren't
feeling it
I really should he use that for the
football guy that just went over him huh
bail whines just throw another one I
have had that kind of battery swamp in
like once or twice but for the most part
I would say it's been mostly fair
yeah that is the TSA
Oh still alive
okay you just fell off
oh okay cool that's like if you bug out
I swear I swear destiny
right
No why would you teleport with them I'd
want it gone
I'm actually just personally now I'm not
even worried so much about the meta of
how iron banner amputees working as much
as I am just not happy with the reward
system that more than anything has upset
me or worse I think
right next to the fire
I hope this is safe caballo he just
nicely laughter I appreciate it
all right so as mentioned the trick was
to just walk through it so we're gonna
try the just walk through it yep nope I
should have jumped at the end now is my
part I just wanted to know if just
walking through it would work or not you
know didn't work trial sucks it's based
on KD not necessarily if anything what's
what's probably not so great about IV
right now is just that uh or not these
trials is that is that it's connection I
think so sometimes you get like really
sweaty games and then sometimes you just
get like weird mediocre games or it's
just like a group of four people just
trying to do their challenges I think
once you'd run ahead now yeah I'm gonna
try to pull him forward that's what I
try to do hopefully not die in the
process thank you Richard
it's like dude
it's all or nothing
no no no no that was at the end I should
have slid fudge what's up Eric Mendez I
believe in weekly he's gonna try to ride
his stare all the way through nope
is that freakin alright maybe I had to
kill that Hobgoblin at some point I
guess do I even bother
I know this is
it's not the business
feel like it's a good idea here
surviving
but he went already almost
oh damn
quickly we leave you gots to run
now again snipe - yeah healing rift yeah
yeah yeah okay oh you got to watch out
for the thingy okay he's good he's made
it I shouldn't work from the bottom run
Forrest run
we're good we're good we're good we got
six minutes - thanks Timothy was kind of
late for me to read that message but
we're good hey what stay low
I should have stayed low next time I
know oh that's weird they didn't do the
out assume it'll pull the board
alright last time
[Music]
well he's gone behind me
should just be shooting the boss if you
like rocket
Wow
okay I guess you could have cheesed it
there is like a cheesy spot here
somewhere
Wow and why
switching guns
[Music]
I'll how it hurts don't burn me okay
that's not good that's not good at all
I was so close to Ewing I think we'll be
okay yeah I know
it's always heated easy to back secure
back yeah well I I believe we're totally
fine we have three minutes and whatever
seconds I'm gonna respond soon so yeah
don't even bother
Oh
Wow this is really bad
okay what
a slap grenade you got slap your name
that's laughs we need it again all right
three minutes I would super ads now
maybe after this
please say there
yeah I use it on the hats for sure once
they start getting crazy I don't want to
kind of like use down the boss to you
though shouldn't also be a mistake
take this you bullet sponge
probably mistake
no I'm gonna die here oh I got a light
thing yeah nailed it
good work Wheatley good work did it no
problem we don't need time we got
nothing but time baby now I should have
popped a coin so we could have got more
stuff out of that but that was good that
was good
mm-hmm we're luck Nova bomb the boss
when he's in the middle yeah he's got it
yeah or smash not so good on the boss
hammers yeah let's fight you my hammers
would have been better I just like
double pulse grenade whoo
all right pretty good pretty good 20
minutes
not bad all right let me quickly add
some of these people will do some iron
Vinay's Wheatley I'm assuming you still
want to do iron banner if not I
appreciate the help in the nightfall
where do we get oh we got a bunch of
people a couple actually let's see some
guy this guy this guy could be a girl
okay so I added like there's like three
or four people there all right cool uh
all right so switch to IB some IV
weapons aunty hope is another gun that
people are using quite a bit oh shoot
I thought I had other weapons Tim I
guess we are gonna have to go mighty
Uriel cupbearer is really good if you
don't have a curtain call if you guys
ever get a cup Bearer you should keep it
I'm gonna blow mine up but yeah go
roster are cool so Wheatley is in for
the IB yeah Lego fort saying I got the
chest piece on the Titan mark for 12
packages I am disappointed I've opened
that 19 packages and I've gotten four
pieces so I guess I can't complain
anymore ah who was where is he was like
devii SHhhh
I think oh hey none of these would
necessarily make sense here cuz I know
okay so these these three I just added
so I can invite two of you guys for now
I should do it based off of who was last
so ace you're gonna you're gonna get
into the next one ace oh this guy's
already playing so I guess we'll invite
the other folks fishy we'll get you in
the next next one he is also playing
everyone's just playing IB and watching
because that's what life is like I
really wish I had di M on this account I
don't let me use ye-olde destiny app or
is it
companion app let's clan alright let me
see if I can move some weapons over we
got Jim beastie
who has my like who has the pulse up
there it is ooh
today it's working for me the other day
it was giving me some problems
we got the fool's remedy we transfer
that to got last hope
transfer that to honey that's fine all
right cool we're gonna use the IP pulse
and we'll try using the IV side arm the
IV side arm is okay it's not great
legend of a curious though if you have
this shocker that's legit
how many do we got okay so guys four
stack all right let's do it guys thank
you guys for joining in on the iron
banner run I will talk slightly about
our banner a bit more now as many people
I mentioned there's a lot of salt going
on with IB and part of that reason is
it's just based on the token system
every 20 you can turn in every 20 is a
package essentially however the only
ways to get coins is to play IB
obviously if you win you get five coins
if you lose you get two coins
there are also daily challenges in the
iron banner so there's three challenges
obviously that's six more tokens total
and then if you finish the daily like
milestone for iron banner that's 15 so
hypothetically in a given day it's
probably easy to get anywhere from what
the 21 from the challenges and then
probably like another 15 to 20 just from
playing losing or winning so probably
looking at 2 packages a day per
character depending on how many
characters you have so the easiest way I
would say is if you have three
characters obviously just do the
challenges and the milestone for the day
and then whatever you get through that
you can probably get net like three at
least three packages if not 5 to 6 and
that would probably be the casual way of
doing it and just hoping your RNG is
good with saladin now if you're trying
to do anything past the challenges and
let's say you only have one character
then the grind is a lot slower obviously
especially if you're playing solo I
think unless you're really good you know
it's still a game type that depends on
your teammates so I just think most
games last the eight minutes like you
barely ever see a mercy anymore it's
very rare to see a mercy and a lot of it
to is team shotting I would say so in
this case they're probably gonna get B
so sometimes you just got a note about
you know keep fighting for a point that
might be dead so we'll go to a I'm gonna
try to grab a here and yeah it's about
not overextending I think a lot of
people overextend myself included I
think one of the most important things
to do is to make sure that
to make sure that you kind of hold the
points and once you get established two
points to kind of have two people at
each or at least two and one and then
have a floater that was very fortuitous
that I live there
mainly because pulse grenade is Opie
they're starting to spawn at sea so
hopefully we can get with captain unreal
here all right hopefully we can get B
also it's about controlling the power
weapons and how you how well you do with
the power weapons
so hopefully Wheatley can do some work
here with the rocket launcher they also
have rocket launcher it appears I don't
really like going this way I don't know
why I did there like what's up down the
new are you oh it's rare to see you in
twitch chat and instead of the Twitter's
my aim wait
terrible so sometimes you know like you
might end up only having one point
that's okay you want to make sure to at
least just maintain that point try to
slay a little bit but yeah this pulse is
pretty good it's got a high rate of fire
it almost kind of reminds me a little
bit of clever dragon you know low-impact
higher right a fire
doing a pretty good job I'm gonna rotate
back to a while you guys hold because
there's someone at a as I had mentioned
it's kind of what happens gonna have a
really hard time holding a alright try
to grab heavy in the Dark Age week they
have go back to anyways ok for now
no I dyed it with heavy
well holding the points gives you more
points right so I mean yeah it's still
ultimately about killing but I mean you
just get less points when you have less
points so just have to do it the
objective
got to to to data be
nice work Wheatley see now we try to now
in a perfect world we're gonna try to
take this I hope he gets that nice
hopefully uh Wheatley can grab their
heavy which would be a pretty clutch
here that's gonna be tough
all right nice work we got oh no he got
they got they're heavy
it's alright though postgame golden guys
nice nice Jim okay you land followed us
alright we're okay though like as long
as we can control these two points we'll
get more points obviously from killing
and destiny fast is good also explosive
one guys taking a though this is how
they get you they try to pull you away
the terrible grenade
damn watch out guys are going into B
this is gonna be delayed for you guys
[Music]
sucks out of a bad trade on my part
alright nice smash captain
don't let me get that heavy no I want to
help support but I didn't necessarily
get out fisted but I got a yeah yeah the
bear trade God mighta so far that's the
one problem with the pulse is it doesn't
have a lot of range unfortunately
nice no one minute still dead even you
can do this your lead okay it's gonna be
a close game
it's about getting trying to slay here
now Jim Beasley's going in it's going in
all right traded at least this is good
though like we pushed them back they
only have one point you know as long as
we play pretty smart here it's gonna be
kind of hard to lose we could even just
like so another pro tip is if you
suicide they don't actually get a kill
and then they can't kill you obviously
so if we just play really slow we're
gonna win this game or just lame it out
there you go
victory good job boys the funny thing
about range is that the ante OD has like
massive range for a for SMG it's like
it's got more pages than the nightshade
which is like insane let me see if I can
show you that's like another weapon that
a lot of people are using is the ante up
d let me see if I can find to where mine
is it's weird
on this character already oh there it is
this guy this guy this guy has so this
guy or hold on this this is a very
comparison this submachine gun has more
range than my pulse rifle it might even
be close to it has more range than the
knit me nameless midnight yeah so about
that I'm still not a fan of this gun I'm
not great with the last hope we could
try running that with I don't like
having two short-range weapons so we'll
go aerial Uriel's and antio on this next
one what's up bro Kenji welcome back so
that's a good match I will like I said
I'll try to get the other player that I
had added on my friends list into the
group at some points if possible he who
controls B wins the game not necessarily
sometimes it's good to have a and C but
there's less maps that where a and C are
good combined
maybe uh I'll tell you when I see it but
most of the time you won't be you
basically take the other point like a
there just to distract them from holding
be Dan the noob I have an Tod and out of
options as smg's yeah an Tod is pretty
beast if you guys know who real crafty
is he uses this a lot of people are
using this gun more recently mob justice
felt okay but it has to be really close
well the Palakkad is kind of interesting
too
let me could try it but you're really
reals is too good let's be earlier
high-caliber rounds is the kind of semi
broken thing I feel like that's why I
might is so good because it has high
caliber round what's up Kevin Deedle
alright this is one my I like this map
quite a bit emperor's respite but I feel
like it's skewed to the team that has a
and B the C feels like you can't really
control B from C so you want a and B on
this map yeah so we're on air so we're
fortunate we want a and B for sure C is
just it just feels awkward like trying
to hold view from there that guy's got a
range weapon I'm not okay with that
well guys how do we let him in there
nice hold watch out for the opie
lightning pulse grenade know the ante oh
how did I lose thank you for killing him
wheelie
I shouldn't have crouched I guess
another thing to try doing I guess if
you're in the Auto rifle battle is to do
the whole life stand out Oh again flanks
it's a it's a Uriel's world though man
it really is look how far he shot me
from that one guy it's got a lot of
range oh we're going for the triple cap
yeah also you want to consider having
energy stability on energy weapons
stability be stuff on your armor if
possible that was my fault they're
losing the opponents have advantage
no job nice rocket hey sometimes I don't
like serials though I don't know it's
really good but it doesn't like yo gate
sometimes you shoot it and maybe that's
just me like you went through me to
throw that grenade we don't want them to
get a an ideal situation here zone
advantage is yours
like I said seeing B's real awkward zone
a lost why that guy challenge
oh [ __ ] we didn't get me my bed's yours
I mean I tried to take a back because
yeah they can have C we want a MB for
sure guys do you play by a better way L
know
five minutes the pendulum could swing
that guy has been hyper aggressive can
we stop them from gaming there have you
oh wow you guys lived shoot him he's
right in front of you we're having some
spicy games here little spicy games
you can kill a seal there what hell it
sounded like he totally casted his
barrier and then he what okay you're
that guy's lagging that was weird
oh we're triple capping no we're not
like I shouldn't be doing this I really
shouldn't be pushing up like this like
whatever they can come to us like they
can't like if you wanted to just hold
sight lines on be like it's like almost
impossible for them to get in like Jim
VC is going and picking them off
we had a shotgun they have a golden gun
and yeah hey guys me tasty milk it kind
of doesn't matter though where are you
from
nothing gonna stop so you're like I
don't know how you're supposed to really
break this you have to have someone go
to a and then that's like the only way
I'm not gonna make it my way I'll take
the trade I'll take the trade you look
like that douche rice gum wow that sucks
but at least I don't know he's internet
famous at least is that you look pleased
maybe it's the haircut alright we got
out we gotta try to kill someone just
legend happiest I don't know what the
range is like not that far wow how did
they completely live damn try aunty Oh
aunty it was a pretty good SMG to me
nice oh we're smashing them now oh
they're taking that overextend
humming Carter and finish this
if I missed anyone that's trying to IB
tell me so we can get some some rotation
hi residents 42 we're out of options
Hank okay here's the other thing I
missed the fact that you could get iron
banner drops from post games I think
it's kind of crazy that you can't at all
like it sucks even like you get that
many purples in general so like why not
have the ability to drop iron banner
armor or weapons from post game like
that was happening in Destiny one like
what like that's just like crazy to me
um but I guess that is what it is all
right we're gonna try outlast taupe and
we'll go nameless nameless Midnight's
actually not bad
donut Koon I liked a more than that
douche Michael from game Tech oh man
Michael hi I'm are you in here to defend
yourself yeah Dan the noob also saying
agreed rewards should be IV items
there's like that doesn't make sense
okay destiny one I be not only could you
get postgame reward iron banner gear
which is random which is fine right I
mean not great but fine but you also had
logical progression you would rank up
from rank 1 to 5 and as you ranked up
from 1 to 5 you would get different
rewards one was obviously very like like
glimmer and whatnot two was okay 3 would
forget like I think 3 was like a
potential for a weapon or armor and so
was 5 and then also on top of that Lord
Saladin actually sold pieces of armor
now he didn't sell all of them he sold
like two types of gloves two types of
helmets and it's like ok hopefully I get
it and then he also sold weapons so you
knew every time like there's like two
weapons or whatever that you could buy
but you would be chasing the rolls I
think part of this whole potential
problem is the fact that weapon perks
aren't random anymore and so there isn't
the Chase for a perfect gun now I kind
of understand why that is because you
could get like a really shitty version
of like a clever dragon where you just
blow it up right away
but I think I would rather have that and
chase like a perfect weapon than what we
have right now which is just like
defined weapon roles we're like okay I
have my fifth last hope do I really need
another one not really unless I'm trying
to get three of every element and so
those are the those are I don't know
just my current issues with it and it's
like the fact that I could potentially
open 40 packages and never get the
gloves for this Titan and I would
probably just be an assault vest and
also like outside of aesthetics is there
really any reason to to play the I be
like I don't know at least in the past
there were weapons that I would strive
for I've heard the iron banner SMG is
good I've heard the iron banner fusions
good but it's not like those weapons are
so much better than other types of guns
like that so like main ingredients
probably comparable or shocking AWS
probably comparable to the wizened
rebuked I think and then the pulse rifle
yeah it's solid but pulse rifles don't
even really exist in the meta right now
what's up slam dude it's like it's like
Auto rifle Scouts right now are we
playing the same map wow we are okay at
least we got the good side
radical Greek beard says they mess up
iron banners the first time I haven't
wanted to play an iron banner I totally
agree with you on that front I was
playing it because I really just want
the armor I think it's really cool but
so far I feel like I've been burned
quite a bit it seems a little smarter
they're not just funneling to okay
that's fine actually but yeah I just
think that
there's a lot to be there's a lot that's
missing that I would like that guys
using a bit over God other side boys
like vigilance wings seems okay but like
the going really feels like more
effective like at close range like why
are we spawning at sea like that doesn't
make sense unless I had a guy pulling me
towards sea which kind of makes sense I
guess please kill him he's really low
thank you
I went back to d1 last week my explosive
rounds Firefly outlaw hero formula damn
that sounds really good too good almost
oh we got all three let's go power
overwhelming oh they're gonna take seat
back that's alright I think got a peek
oh we're gonna we gonna we gonna go in
there alright we going in there now if
that was a bad idea totally ran right
into all their stuff
I was not worth it at least not to go 3
into the same spot like that let's not
give him me though it's really not give
them a please dang it dang it all right
I gotta get back don't worry we'll get
it back
the trick to last hope is hipfire you
said you had issues with it okay I'll
try to hit fire anymore that makes sense
no the flinch the GD flinch from
high-caliber rounds
well can we steal the heavy steel
they're heavy yeah who uses grenade
launchers right I know this is exactly
why no one's gonna get launches oh I
just shot my guy in the head
all right getting a bit overzealous
trying to like take three points here
not worth there's one behind you Jim no
all right more hipfire
we need more hipfire do you feel so
weird just so weird a fire
oh the golden I know I was there hair
smash the point
nice nice Jim nice you grenade launcher
ah yeah it's fun to mix it up I didn't
play the games actually decent and I'm
getting carried right now getting
backpacks the guy I've eaten a lot eerie
sounds good for bosses has high direct
hit down three minutes remain keep the
pressure on you have them alright so far
so good
as I say that stone car kills three of
us and they take Pete I think they'll be
fine
hello sword they're gonna try to triple
Kappas back possibly yeah looks like
it's happening Dixie oh that was not
good
you captured Zone C
cut their momentum keep pushing I'll
walk through my things
other side
I think it's obviously flying over just
a shell and just hold one coin and play
the game is one of the best weapons yeah
I was
they cast a golden
shot twice
Oh
Oh can they come back skills good tip
Dan got a hipfire more foo Jim got a got
an exact grants Bru word if Coyle is
decent but you only get one shot I think
Papa coin here I don't know I didn't pop
a coin sooner the animation for 80s with
sidearms is misleading makes it look
like heavy recoil yeah could that make
some sense oh I ended up at the top yeah
snuck my way in there but 1.5 Katie
that's so great that's a great head to
Katie earlier alright we'll do one more
let's do one more guys probably call it
a stream it's been a good one I
appreciate all the help I appreciate the
people I'm playing with right now we got
Jim xB ste got captain and real go Sagan
which is a friend from the chat
do I have any other weapons all right
we'll try using the IB Auto I think I
think it's mediocre and I will use a
lacking if you guys have not gone to
Manon on sr4 you guys need to get one
it's pretty solid gun here I'll use it
for like a hot second
it's a scout rifle that has explosive
rounds as an energy weapon kind of
shoots like a hung jury or a to lock it
is pretty good she's kind of slow though
what's midnight 180 yeah yeah Wheatley
the puppy you're slow says J M yeah look
look who's in the chat look who he is Oh
broke down oh man oh no no no no no no
yesterday nah dude you got to keep them
on on on my one friend hasn't gone dumb
went on on and he's broken now if I like
1500 weapon parts of the gunsmith feels
bad
let's try play that we're gonna try to
play the game you know I got that man on
nine nice J I'm saying them but not not
for the win
does everybody Eric Turk get the Iron
Man Banner reputation reward or he's
limited to one character uh if you're
talking about the milestone you can do
that three times a day so like if you
have three characters you could do that
on each character the milestone daily
challenge and then there's also the
daily you could turn in the you can turn
in your coins on any of your characters
though so whoever you want your arm
we're set on could do it on that for me
it's been tightening very open spots
take that that one no come on iron
banner OTO oh of course that makes sense
actually
I'm not salty that you're using a side
busted
so I can't get the hot thing I burn
charts which ones that happen be
I'm not sure which one that is do I have
it and not even know I try to keep one
of everything but you know that doesn't
always happen
and Jim just does not care
I'm a tea bag method so I do the Crouch
Stan Crouch standing like this
what like wall I'm shooters it's sort of
help I'd like to try this mental ocean
rockets Rockets is heading to eventually
you be saying the V I'm saying this like
they can hear me right now obviously
they can I'm gonna try to bait this
baited one rocket I did not pay this he
killed me with a second one but I have a
bomb that killed two so really I want
that exchange
oh they got B come on got the l du
Bellay there
jeez this thing is so weak got it
whoa I'm so dead
ah someone clean them up that's why we
got AMC just fine sick martyrdom bro
yeah I'm so dead why is he not pushing
me you just push me right now
boring
hey so you don't have to watch if you
don't want to submit you look pleased
and he lost advantages yours
don't see capture zone advantages yours
isn't over not anymore
total control as you can see can't keep
them lost outlaw makes everything good
yeah it could be
that's pretty sloppy they've got the job
done the battlefield is yours finish
yeah
Zone B lost Zone C captured this is the
moment iron Lords live for zone C lost
three minutes remain
keep the pressure on you have them come
on play the game you got to make play of
the games
DJ saying talking about warframe I've
heard this mate
No
June BC take care of him
come and help you
no he's got tether
ah damn you tether
yo remember the days when I killed
someone with the I don't know
[ __ ]
you know they're everywhere
man
and this blind fire
we did it yay hate ad ever play puppy
now I have a place pokey temples the
cafe it's the carrot on the stick for
you Dan that one thing yeah shotgun Pete
I miss the old lobby with Danny and
Kevin yeah I miss them but Danny is
doing cool stuff on noclip obviously
Kevin is doing great stuff at Larian
studios he worked on the vanity to a few
people don't know that
Kevin Vanhorn old reviews hetero reviews
I believe I forget the exact terminology
but yeah all right let's I'm gonna head
to the tower so that I can be greatly
disappointed by my my bro
salad bar I'm hoping for a little bit of
streamers luck I can't cancel because
it's still in spit maybe we have enough
for note we're short damn oh wait no we
do have enough for two packages cuz I
have a the turnin come on destiny let me
out alright there you go
whoa that was weird it's like some ships
flew away but they're still okay there
you go people are leaving the party
that's totally fine thank you Jim or no
who just left who did I just miss dammit
director
it was kept in unreal
managing reviews editor than I think Bob
Jones
I think that's Peters current title
thank you Wheatly for the help and the
nightfall glad we got that done a little
sloppy but we only have two people so
attempt is now on yep tourists typical
IDI to show up late just like he didn't
go to e3 this year killed me because you
know you just wasn't there I'm I miss my
brother from Down Under
I had some notification about a
legendary something oh that was a for
overwatch alrighty
the question is well we get streamers
luck or are we gonna get pwned and we
get pwned but hopefully we don't get
pwned
oh that's at 305 home what do I have it
300 home that oh don't sucks
some duck iron Boehner I all I only have
the iron boner if he gives me the gloves
which I'm gonna guess he's not going to
here's Saladin you weren't sure he
showed up in the tower he has his little
own space his giant iron banner Gong
slash coin something tore the crucible
are you in work office or at home I am
at the office right now all right so
there's your daily for the 15 tokens
here we go
today he's Ingram for $2.99 first day it
was 300 yesterday toes 298 so that's
another thing you could consider is you
could wait on all your um engrams to
hope that if you're already 300 that he
has 300 engrams because otherwise this
thing's in a roll 299 obviously here
goes number one you got the hand cannon
already have that
and here comes package number two and we
got the fool's remedy again so dupe City
as to be expected it is what it is
I have like two of these hand cannons
now I have I would have rather had
gotten though the fusion or the SMG I
still haven't gotten either one find
that crazy but it happens
there's my extra home that I'm never
going to take out yeah pretty much
that's what we call trashed here trashed
here it's alright I guess if I if it was
so easy to get everything I wouldn't
probably be playing but then technically
I would be working on my other
characters so I would be playing I heard
this isn't that good
Timothy karen says captain and real says
thank you very much good luck thank you
it's got outlaw I guess that's okay it's
one of those high impacts hand Canyon so
if you're inaccurate and you're getting
shaken up by our friend
Ariel's gift you're probably gonna get
rekt oh what's up Jim all right let's
sprinkle some salt because I am salty
that that happened but you know I'll
still play Ironman obviously because I
just tend to do that I really I really
do want to finish my set of instead of
iron banner armor will it happen will or
not I have no idea I have a couple more
days
I have Daniel jr. I have opened
I believe 21 packages the only way to
tell is what this this emblem and then I
got to go to coin I've opened 21
packages of which I've gotten mostly
everything I'm missing the gloves and
then I'm missing the fusion and the SMG
I think I just really want this set
maybe I'll do it on warlock it's just
this grind to even get wonderful set has
been arduous to say the least I really
want to kind of just get it over with
and then maybe I'll do warlock I don't
know I might just go to that thing where
I just do three a day where I just do
the daily challenges and the milestone
challenge and call it a day and hope
that my warlock gets most of it I think
I really only want the helmet on warlock
so anyways I do appreciate you guys all
tuning in
tomorrow is Friday the 13th obviously oh
you need to you need to live vicariously
through me because of my exotics alright
I'll open that real quick Rahul and
funny we're going to Rahul
there's nothing I need on my Titan which
is kind of shitty obviously because then
what could I what do I want
like nothing there's nothing I want I'm
missing armor on hunter and warlock so
here we go
hallo fire heart and lion rampant again
sick I'm so excited to have another line
yeah mmhmm yep that's kind of how it
goes we could dump it was greatly
improves the recharge rate of your solar
abilities or hunting hands kind of
whatever is we're gonna blow it up and
put it into our raid armor but yeah
that's that whoop-dee-doo damn that's
420 tokens magical 420 well apparently
it wasn't
magical yeah anyways thanks guys
tomorrow's Friday the 13th as I
mentioned so we'll probably play some
type of scary game I don't know what it
is yet to be honest but I think it
should be good anyways I hope you guys
tune in tomorrow at 11 if not we're
alive every day at 11 if you haven't hit
that follow button on Twitch once you do
us if they ever hit that followed button
or hit that sub 1 on youtube so you can
get notified of when we go live and also
when we put up cool features and all
that fun stuff so until next time guys I
hope you have a good Thursday thanks to
all the gentleman or generally generally
ladies that have been helping me today
on the iron banner and the nightfall we
should try to do this more often I'll
see if I can do something next week with
you all it's fun to have you guys
playing with me thanks guys see you
later
mmm is the key
[Music]